А коли це сальдо був чесною людиною А з
якого ляду ми були це будемо думати що
сальдо має казати казав людям правду Ну
ми хоч трохи залізти в інтернет і
почитати новини і почитати новини за
минулі роки за діяльність цього коли вже
він не був мером здається в домінікані
Так його взяли за дубку за за що Та там
я вже й не пам'ятаю Ну це Шахрай ну це
злодії Шахрай воно хитре воно підступне
воно
подлючить воно не це воно не гідне
навіть слова людина воно жило тут серед
херсонців і зробити таке з херсоном це
це говорити в пеклі просто горіти йому в
пеклі оце що я можу сказати нічого Він
не заслуговує більше Та ненавиділи вони
людей ви розумієте всі хто привів сюди
вони ненавиділи людей ну це
правда Ну нащо вони сюди прийшли не не з
добром це ж Ну ви бачите що вони зробили
з херсоном тут зруйновано все вони
руйнують
вони руйнують саме найважливіше дитячі
будинки
Ну як це лікарні Ну як це ну як це
кругом ставились свої завезені
оці русняві
У нас же ж не як не гуманітарних
коридорів Не було нічого ми ми терпіли
як могли не ліків нормальних те що
приводили привозили ліки і вони
продавалися отак ото на гарячому сонці з
машин Ну і ви розумієте яка якість ліків
російських це ото известь якась замішана
на глині оце все Людей багато виїхало
більшість херсонців виїхало і я розумію
їх правильно зробили ну це не кожен
витримає
ви знаєте люди які не хотіли розбиратися
ті пенсійного віку дуже глибоко
пенсійного віку Оце я чула таку риторику
вже від інших ну при сальдо був порядок
Вони не розуміють навіть що це був Це
був непорядок Ну вони тоді були молоді
тому вони сприймали це як порядок
ніякого порядку не було
варто було виїхати за межі Херсонської
області
поїздити трошки Україною і побачити що
Херсон потерпає Херсон завжди пас задніх
ну це правда В нас є такий мікрорайон
острів Який зараз затоплений я сама з
мікрорайону острів
те що він був під постійними обстрілами
після звільнення
те що
до
звільнення Ми просиділи
ну близько трохи більше місяця без води
світла
без опалення в холодних квартирах і
були блокпости які вели на той
острів і ми не могли навіть ви їх Ну ми
могли виїхати але це ризик тебе будемо
могли обшукати над тобою ми з тобою
могли зробити все що завгодно звісно
люди виїжджали звісно люди їздили але
там і ціни були скажені і магазини майже
не працювали
і
бомбосховищ там немає там навіть
подвалів немає там на ну навіть подвалів
немає ви уявляєте там для того щоб
залізти в подвал треба рачки лізти
каналізаційних труб
про які бомбосховище має йти немає там
водостоки там забиті і Влада навіть і
водостоки не робила наше
колихає він їх не робив ті водостоки бо
їх не видно людям він робив фонтани він
робив картинку щоб людям було приємно
він саджав цвіти робив фонтани навіть
при окупації що зробив сальдо фонтани
мріяв включить який фонтани коли
перебили водопостачання для Миколаєва і
Миколаїв сидів потерпав без води ми
знали це в окупації що Миколаїв сидить
потерпає без води а з наш значить мир
хотів включити фонтани це виглядало як
знущання нам херсонцем було боляче бо ми
були тоді з водою Я дуже хочу щастя
моєму місту я тому і не виїхала Я тому і
не Виїду я не можу покинути моє місто Я
сподіваюсь ви знаєте В мене такі
роздвоєні такі думки
перша Я розумію що буде дуже важко
тому що багато хто не повернеться тому
що
молодь сюди не захоче зараз їхати тому
що місто
зруйноване тут і так не було багато
інфраструктури такої розвитку
А зараз так Тим паче А
леж я сподіваюсь на інвестиції
закордону що все ж якось люди захочуть
відновити наше місце місто Я сподіваюсь
на любов людей до нашого міста на любов
херсонців Я дуже сподіваюся Я дуже
сподіваюся я не можу не думати що нашому
місту кінець Я не хочу в це вірити Я
хочу щоб бачити щоб Херсон був квітучий
Я дуже хочу бачити Херсон квітуча зараз
після повені після того що в нас
змінився ландшафт Херсонській області
лівого берега
знаєте Спочатку треба
Спочатку треба перемогти а далі
будемо лупатися